good afternoon and welcome to nature's
returns investing in ecosystem services
a webinar speaker series hosted by the
Yale Center for business on the
environment that addresses the growing
importance of ecosystem service
valuation and investment my name is
Karina Mahone and I will be your host
for this afternoon's discussion titled
water in the West how impact investing
can help this webinar is the first in
our mini series on capital flows
catalyzing investments in water
resources this miniseries has made has
been made possible through a partnership
with a conservation finance Network a
new joint effort to provide robust
online resources for conservation
finance together we will launch a new
CFN website co-host the nature's returns
webinar series as we're doing today and
provide coverage of developments across
the field we're pleased to have with us
today Ricardo Beyond and Tom Melton of
encourage capital and Peter called of
Squire patton boggs who will share
findings from the new report liquid
assets investing for impact in the
Colorado River Basin this report
reflects work by encouraged capital and
square patton boggs in collaboration
with the walton family foundation to
identify potential impact investments
that could be successfully deployed to
finance water resource solutions
generate related environmental benefits
and create a financial return it
outlines 11 promising impact investment
strategies that have been grouped into
nine separate investment blueprints
while these blueprints could potentially
be deployed in many parts of the West
this investigation has focused on the
Colorado River Basin one of the most
water stressed watersheds in the western
United States and one of the most
heavily regulated and developed river
systems in the world before I hand it
off to Ricardo we would like to remind
our listeners that we welcome
any questions you might have and will
direct them towards speakers at the
conclusion of the talk you can type
questions directly to the go to chat
window and with that we welcome Ricardo
beyond Tom Melton and Peter called to
nature's returns Ricardo Thank You
Korina so um so we thought we'd do is
take you very very briefly through the
work we did in this report on the
Colorado River and try and leave as much
time for questions by way of quick and
introduction encourage capital is the
merger of two entities one was echo
asset management partners which I helped
co-found and the other one is Wolfensohn
fund management and the idea of
encouraged capital is to come up with
investment approaches that help solve
critical environmental problems so Tom
and I both work at and encourage and
I'll pass it over very briefly to to
Peter to introduce Squire patton boggs
hello this is Peter cult I'm a partner
with Squire patton boggs based here in
Phoenix where I manage our western water
natural resources practice and have been
working pretty extensively over the last
15 or 16 years on water scarcity issues
in the Colorado River Basin and been
thrilled to hook up with encourage
capital in order to produce this report
thank you Peter um so basically the
history of this report is that I'd
encourage we'd begun to look at how you
can kind of turn the way impact
investment is done on its head the
feeling we felt going into and part of
the reason we created encourage was that
we felt that the impact investing that
was being done out there was sort of
coming at it from an asset management
perspective and people were saying you
know I do real estate investing or I do
venture capital investing and how do i
layer impact into those and that
encouraged what we wanted to do was turn
it around and design a
arm from the ground up for impact and
what that means is and it's starting to
ask questions of yourself and saying
okay instead of saying I do real estate
how do i layer an impact you say well
what is the impact I want to have what
are the problems I'm trying to solve and
how do you design the solutions and in
that vein we began to work with Peter
and with the walton family foundation
around the very particular and sticky
problem of the colorado river basin and
and so we said okay well what are the
issues in the Colorado and we were quite
upfront and encourage that we know
little or nothing or knew little or
nothing about the Colorado and that we
needed to be teamed up with an expert
like Peter and there are a few things
Peter doesn't know about the Colorado
River so it was a it was a good team and
so what we did was look at the problems
of the Colorado and try to come up with
as Karina said somewhere between nine
and eleven ideas for impact investing in
the Colorado that will also help address
the the serious social environmental and
other problems of of the river and we've
put all of those out there they have you
know a model a sort of blueprint with a
model ideas and they're out in the
public domain the report is going to be
printed and launched this week so you're
getting a little bit of a preview of
what it looks like so with that I'll
pass it over to the Peter to really talk
about what are the what are the issues
of the Colorado before Tom and I walk
you guys through some of the potential
ideas that we've come up with thanks for
product yeah so so the Mac you're
looking at is a map of the western
United States and the sort of watersheds
stress that we're seeing and i think is
as everybody knows the western United
States is now facing some fairly
significant water problems of course
California has been getting a lot of
press lately but most of the western
United States has been facing some water
scarcity problems over the
past decade or more as a result of both
combination of a sort of current drought
conditions but maybe more importantly
the development of water in the West and
sort of long-term over use of water
resources and those problems are
basically projected to get worse going
forward the map you're looking at is a
map produced by a series of researchers
that sort of projecting out what water
stress in the West is going to look like
moving into the future basically green
is good red is bad and as you can see
the stress in that system is of course
concentrated in the west and very
significantly in a region of the country
which corresponds more or less to the
outlines of the Colorado River Basin
going to go out to the next one right
now so this is a map of the Colorado
River Basin it's composed of seven US
states and two Mexican States Utah
Wyoming Colorado New Mexico comprised
the upper basin of the Colorado River
Nevada Arizona and California composed
the lower basin along with Mexico the
states of Baja California and Sonora the
map sort of shows the hydrologic
boundary of the basin but also a number
of areas outside the basin where water
is used ultimately supports about 40
million people about five and a half
million acres of irrigated farmland
pretty much pretty close on the order of
that twenty percent of u.s. gdp is
supported either directly or indirectly
by the water produced by the basin but
it's also comprised that is exhibit some
very extreme levels of water variability
where a good year might yield five times
as much water as dry year and as a
result of that there's been significant
infrastructure development in the basin
to try and control that variability and
convert it into a stable water supply
that can be used for agriculture in
cities and so forth which is turned it
into
pretty much the most heavily regulated
river system in the world we very
closely control the water of this system
we can account for virtually every drop
and where it goes in fact the river
itself has not flowed to the ocean since
the 1960s because it is completely
consumed by humans within before it
reaches the ocean that problem has sort
of created one of the sort of
fundamental issues of the basin which is
that it allocates the law of the river
which is the legal system we use to
regulate it actually allocates quite a
bit more water than actually exists and
that's creating some interesting
problems I'll talk about in a second
what that legal system is done is
effectively converted that natural basin
into this plumbing system that you're
seeing on the left side and with a
series of reservoirs and diversions that
use and reuse water along it's like
multiple times along the way that's left
behind quite an environmental legacy
that is now creating some significant
problems for us we had a century of fire
suppression that has left us with pretty
heavily overgrown and very fire-prone
forests in which we're seeing
catastrophic fires more than a century
of grazing which has eliminated most of
the native natural grasslands and led to
the spread of invasive which changes the
hydrologic cycle significantly we've had
dams and diversions that have reduced
anime case has eliminated a lot of
stream flow in the basin and certainly
changed its timing leaving to loss of a
lot of native riparian ecosystems and
then agriculture and cities are
effectively as I mentioned using
essentially all of the water produced by
this system and in fact are exporting
quite a bit of that water outside the
hydrologic boundaries of the basins the
cities like Denver Los Angeles San Diego
that rely on the river as well as other
issues around water quality soil health
all those things together have combined
to sort of significantly stress the
environment of this basin and also
change the hydrologic cycle
important ways that are now leading to
reduced supplies even as we are
continuing to grow our demand on the
basic next slide over this is a graph
coming out of a recent study conducted
by the Bureau of Reclamation of the
Colorado River basin study which looked
at among other things the relationship
between supply and demand going into the
future and which you can see from this
is that basically as i was around two
thousand three the red line which
represents water use by humans in the
basin sort of intersected that blue line
which is water supply produced service
water supply produced by the natural
systems this basin and since around two
thousand three human use has effectively
exceeded that natural supply on a
reliable basis and that is in fact
projected to get worse as time goes on
as a result of increasing demand in the
basin just accounting for some just the
sort of projected growths and demand
we're expecting to see a shortfall of
around twenty percent within the next
few decades under some of the worst case
scenarios it's much worse than that
maybe upwards of fifty percent and
that's without accounting for the very
extensive use of groundwater in this
basin which drives that supply demand
relationship even out further out of
whack if you go to the next one one of
the interesting features of that over
uses that we are now operating within
the lower basin of the Colorado River in
a consistent water deficit situation in
which we use more water than the system
can reliably produce that's actually
been occurring for some time but had
been it not generated a serious problem
because there had been a lot of excess
water flowing out of the upper basin
states that we're not using it but in
light of the drought and continued
development in the upper basin we're no
longer seeing those excess flows which
is sort of revealed this deficit
for what it is this is a graph showing
the level of late need which is the
major basin storage storage reservoir
for the lower basin states of the this
primary source of supply for Arizona
California and Nevada for Colorado River
water and projecting out into the future
what would happen if simply the last 10
years were repeated as you can see the
lake the clients precipitously as it
goes below that red line shortages are
going to be imposed on users in the
lower basin as it approaches the bottom
of that graph those shortages could
become potentially quite catastrophic
but what's interesting about that
decline is it has very little to do with
drought that is in fact the cause that
is in fact the result of this overuse
where we're simply just using more water
than the system is producing your
respective of drought in fact the only
hydrology in that graph is that little
uptick around 2011-2012 where we
actually had a very wet year and that
helped us to bring some reservoir levels
back up but in the absence of that extra
water the lake will reliably decline and
that's generating now some fairly
significant risk for water users
particularly the lower basin the upper
basin faces some similar challenges go
to the next slide so fundamentally what
the users are in this basin are now
facing is a series of pretty significant
growing water risks that are moving the
system towards what we sort of refer to
as a permanent shorted and those risks
now threaten agricultural users as we've
seen examples of what can happen with
that in the state of California in this
past year hydropower generation where we
are very close now the points where both
lakes need in powell to potentially stop
producing hydropower for the Western
grid miss apologies who tended to
develop later in the basin and therefore
under the water right system that we
have that Awards water rights to the
first
a sort of first come first serve basis
the cities are in threat of losing
supply we're facing increasing supply
uncertainty and with that sort of
attendant obviously economic impacts on
other industries but it also of course
is creating very significant risks for
ecosystems and the environment as
because those were those uses tend to
not have recognized rights to water as
the system becomes tighter and stress
increases the pressure on the remaining
environmental resources in the basin is
only increased that risk is being driven
by a whole series of factors certainly
central to that that overuse problem
that we were talking about but that is
an issue that is only worse in the face
of climate change this Basin has
experienced very noticeable and and
well-documented increases in temperature
as well as changes in landscape as a
result we believe of climate change that
are beginning to impact water supply we
are of course overusing groundwater
which can impact surface water systems
as well there's our legal system creates
incentives to use water or face the loss
of water rights even when that may not
in fact be the most efficient things do
or the best thing to do it is built on
rigid allocations of water rights that
don't necessarily respond well to
changes in natural variability on all of
that has been driving some very
significant changes and conversations on
this river system about how it is we're
going to manage increasing use in the
future and there's been tremendous
progress over the last decade with new
agreements between the basin states some
new international agreements between the
US and Mexico all of which are trying to
focus on how to manage water risk but at
the moment the interventions that are
occurring as a result of that are really
only occurring in a fraction of the
scale that they're potentially need to
be in order to man
those issues and it's really that that
issue which has sort of led the focus of
our report that's not but fundamentally
those problems are really beginning to
develop at the rate and a scale that is
really pushing well beyond the ability
of our traditional institutions to
address while and in many cases this is
happening in places that have a sort of
limited ability to sort of pay for
solutions through the sort of
traditional means or they're happening
in places where in a sort of Commons
environment where like forests house or
grass Plains health where the impacts of
the changes that are occurring are
distributed across all users but there's
no one necessarily no specific
beneficiaries in a position to pay for
those interventions as a result of that
there really is a potential for some
significant investment value as well as
public value the extent that we can
identify investment strategies that get
at those issues and fundamentally that
really is going to be about managing
this variability managing this risk
there will clearly be a need for some
reallocation of water supply between
those that have it and those that need
it in the future but also maybe more
fundamentally a need for new kinds of
institutions that help us to increase
the flexibility of the way we use water
in the Colorado River Basin as well as
elsewhere in the West and then really
begin to search for solutions that meet
the needs or cross-cutting needs of
Agriculture cities and the environment
and so and that that sort of thesis i
think has been sort of fundamental to
the effort we made in this report to
identify potential investment strategies
so with that I will turn it back over to
Ricardo and Tom thanks Peter and so as
you can see if you didn't already know
the situation in the Colorado is is very
very dire and only going to get worse
and it's not just about the current
drought and it's not something that will
be solved if it rains a bit
this isn't this is a systemic problem
that needs to be addressed in a systemic
manner and you know there's all kinds of
problems and in the system including you
know the the way rights are allocated
the way rights are can or cannot be
traded in different places and as as
Peter sometimes talks about you know the
fact that there are many many different
sort of rights regimes in the system but
what we really need to do is manage risk
and given the situation what can we do
and and truly this report comes out of a
feeling that that no amount of
philanthropy will be able to solve this
problem we need to figure out ways that
private capital can come in and play a
role in changing the way the system
works and in providing some solutions to
this this huge problem and if Peter
points out you know you know this may be
a problem that is really really dire and
stark and visible in the Colorado but
it's also a problem that that many other
river systems around the world face so
perhaps if we can do go some ways
towards solving them in the Colorado we
might be able to do something outside of
the Colorado as well so that was also in
the back of our minds as we prepared
this report so what we did was once we
looked at the problems and highlighted
all the issues that that Peter mentioned
and we should say that our report is it
is going to be out there it's going to
be totally public or be happy to send it
to everyone it's going to be quite long
because it goes into these problems in
depth and it also goes into some
potential solutions and this is what we
want to get into now you know we we kind
of group them into sort of four
categories watershed enhancement which I
think it was a sort of supply of water
then the use of water in sort of two
categories agricultural water use which
happens to be the biggest user of water
in the basin somewhere on the order of
seventy eighty percent then municipal
water use and infrastructure and then
market development so what we will do is
not go into all of those but try to
spend a bit of time on a couple of them
that we think are interesting and on
that note I'll turn it over to Tom sure
thanks Ricardo like one of the key
points on this slide to to highlight is
the strategies that we've selected here
importantly do not necessarily require
policy change they're also meant to be
innovative and you know perhaps for the
work that we do maybe most importantly
they're they're meant to be profitable
so these are these are private capital
investment like solutions and so you
know we'll walk through an example of
them just to give you a 2-second
description of each under watershed
enhancement for cell treatments is
really focusing on preventing
catastrophic wildfires by funding
prevention treatments for stressed
watersheds that experience wildfire
tamarisk removal and restoration which
is B focuses on invasive species letter
C holistic Land Management this is about
sustainable ranching similar to the
savory method crop conversion techniques
this is about efficient use of irrigated
water rights and and the crop type
that's that's using that irrigated water
the way that it's also being delivered
commodity index dry your option which is
letter e this is really focused on a
risk sharing agreement that pays farmers
a market rate for their water in years
where they don't when they don't grow
any crops under the municipal sections
the first one their system loss paper
performance essentially focusing on
fixing leaky pipes and under me
unmetered connections green bond with
sustainable sustainability conditions is
primarily focused on financing green
infrastructure solutions and affordable
rates for municipalities and stressed
watersheds and then the last to market
development the next generation water
trust is focused on utilizing a trust
structure that supports an investment
channel that self funding so it's
reinventing the way that water trust
reused in water storage trading is about
a market-based system that allows for
the possibility of removing the user
loser provisions that exist in the in
the basin
um and having a market trading mechanism
for that um I think we go to the next
slide Ricardo one of the structures that
we wanted to walk through to just
explain how this works is letter A the
first one that I mentioned on forest
health treatments the idea here is
primarily focused on the fact that the
u.s. Forest Service spends about a
billion and a half to two billion
dollars a year on fire suppression even
over the past two years the the u.s.
Forest Service has pulled around a
billion dollars from non suppression
programs into fire suppression so
there's a very vicious cycle of
underfunding fire prevention that leads
to larger and more catastrophic
wildfires every year and so this this
solution is meant to interrupt that
cycle and and to reduce the high
severity wildfires by using funds to pay
for prevention that will be paid back
through reduced wildfire suppression
costs in time this structure is very
similar to the social impact bond
structure that many people have heard
about obviously this is structured for
environmental benefit but then it also
has some innovative concepts to it
specifically related to the payment
repayment structure that that make it
unique so as you can see from the from
the boxes that are here on the screen
there the investment vehicle the LLC is
funded by private investors and it would
establish a contract with a principal
payment party such as the u.s. Forest
Service to pay for services you know
provided by the investment vehicle which
would include forest thinning so the the
two payment groups that will come in the
pencil payment provider and the
secondary interest payment provider will
essentially repay the funds borrowed you
can think of the principal payment
provider like the u.s. Forest Service
who pays money every year for
suppression you can think of the
secondary or interest payment watershed
fund payment provider is someone like a
non-profit NGO who's interested
and removing risk in the watershed or
maybe a water utility receives a certain
amount of water every year for its rate
base in the area as I mentioned before
the the funds that come into the
investment vehicle then paid out be paid
out the contractors who will essentially
do the forest treatment processes which
in this case would be thinning the the
payments that go to the contractors to
actually do the finning the thing in the
watershed have to be verified by an
evaluator and this third-party evaluator
will look to see that not only have the
thinning practices taken place but also
the effectiveness of those sending
practices and I think what's important
here from a water standpoint is not only
do these thinning practices reduce the
risk of high severity wildfire but
there's also the potential for increased
stream flow from the watershed in some
cases upwards to twenty percent and the
water quality would also be much higher
to the extent these treatments take
place we could flip to the so this is
the result you can flip all the way
Ricardo this is the result of the actual
thinning that takes place and the and
the water yield benefits from the
watershed and when the structure takes
place upon success the last few arrows
will come up which would be the
repayment of the principal to the
investment vehicle as funded by the
private investor as well as some form of
interest payment from the watershed fund
to the private investor and what's
innovative here again is the fact that
you're really breaking down this
structure and it is pay for performance
but it's based on not just the 60
ultimate ultimate success of the forest
thinning practices but also overtime
potential increase stream flow as well
as reduced risk from that watershed and
that will generally be paid by the
secondary or interest payment provider
through the watershed fund now with just
that
that you know as Tom said the Forest
Service is in a vicious cycle where it's
essentially taking money from fire
prevention to fight fires and what we're
trying to do with this structure in a
way is turn that on its head and borrow
from future firefighting to pay for fire
prevention and we've talked to the
Forest Service about this and they're
quite keen on on seeing how we can do
something like this you know it's not
going to be straightforward or easy in
particular dealing with the contracting
issues around Forest Service Forest
Service has obviously never done a
contract like this and getting a
contract like this could actually be
quite difficult but if we manage to to
crack this nut there's you know billions
and billions of dollars that the Forest
Service spends on on firefighting and
fire prevention that could be made much
more effective yeah and I think maybe
just one other thing to add this is
Peter was the there is a significant
interest in in the car on a river basin
but I think increasingly another
watersheds in this sort of gnashing of
creating some sort of water should fund
it's just begun to happen in the number
of watersheds around the world most of
the investment structures that we've
developed actually do not rely on
something like that this is one of the
ones that does but for relatively what I
think was interesting to me about this
research was that we found was that for
relatively small amounts of money
potentially in order of magnitude less
than what we have been sort of testing
out in the Colorado River Basin through
a pilot program where we've been trying
to develop some funds to actually pay
for sort of watershed level benefits or
pay people to use less water in order to
kind of fit system res Wars the fur you
know substantially less money than we've
had to pay through sort of more direct
means something like this could actually
help to facilitate for watershed health
investments at pretty significant scales
and they helped make an investment like
this
much more workable so rather than paying
several hundred dollars an acre foot to
save water through farm conservation
maybe for ten twenty thirty dollars an
acre foot water users innovation could
help to create sort of watershed health
benefits that help improve overall
surplus so we're conscious of kind of
finish quickly to get two questions so
we'll move a little bit quickly through
the the remaining slides Tom I don't
know if you want to finish off no I just
for the for the benefit of folks who
will hold this slide after the
presentation this is meant to be a
relative comparison of all the
strategies that we came up with in the
report and so you can see these on a
scale of measuring the impact social
environmental impact as compared to the
financial return and then the size of
the bubble is based on the market size
of the transaction and volume of
transactions so this gives you a sense
of all the various strategies that we
came up with and where they sort of fit
on on an investing or an impact
investing landscape yeah and as you can
see that there's a couple of interesting
ones there in green in particular see
which we felt could have a pretty high
impact in a pretty high financial return
that one is simply changing the way
ranching is done or agricultural crop
production in the cases of number D is
done and benefiting from the water
savings but also benefiting from
increases in yield and potentially
increased value of real estate so that
looks like a pretty traditional either
ranching or agricultural fund with a
water kicker and while you know trading
of water rights and the monetization of
saved water is not possible everywhere
in the Colorado basin it is possible in
some places so you know focusing that
those those activities in places where
that is possible would be key and also
just a word on the impact as Peter
mentioned every drop of water in the
Colorado is
used multiple times before it even hits
Mexico let alone the the ocean if it
ever reaches it so you know it's it's
not quite as easy as just saving water
because if you like use less water as an
agricultural producer there's chances
are somebody is relying on your outflows
to do something with that water so
there's always unintended consequences
and so in in in doing this we've always
tried to keep an eye on some of those
unintended consequences and try to
create approaches or ideas that could be
financeable and it could have a return
for investors so just to finish off what
we believe is that there is a huge
potential for impact investing to play a
role in addressing the water issues of
the Colorado you know I think that as
the pressures that Peter outline so well
continue to grow there's going to be
more pressure to to create the types of
policy changes to use water differently
to figure out the way to make the rules
better but there's also going to be a
tremendous amount of value in moving to
more water efficient better water use
systems on the Colorado and if that is
the case then there's a potential for
impact investing to play a key role I
just add that as P is as Tom pointed out
you know we tried to come up with ideas
that do not rely on policy change so
these don't rely on policy change and in
fact some of them if the policy changes
so for instance if if trading is allowed
some of the returns on these could
actually go up so um I think I'll just
leave it at that and the interest of
getting as many questions and
interaction as possible that sound good
kinda sounds good thank you Peter
Tallman Ricardo we'd like to open up the
remainder of our time to questions from
our audience just a reminder questions
can be shared via the gotomeeting chat
window we have a number of questions
already from the audience the first
comes from Lizzie years of fire
suppression have created unhealthy
forests that are less diver
Chris and susceptible to catastrophic
wildfire to what extent does the
financial model in corporate business
management practices address these best
management practices no sorry my sorry
to what extent as a financial model
incorporate best management practices
well I mean I think that the the idea of
this that particular fire suppression
bond is to bring forward the payments to
allow payment to happen to do the best
management practices we wouldn't design
what those best management practices are
we work closely with the forest managers
and the experts to figure out what they
are but the problem is even if we knew
what they were or we even though we know
what many of them are i should say
before service isn't able to pay for
them just because as we said every year
that it sets aside money to prevent
wildfires and to do those best
management practices the wildfire season
gets out of control and they end up
having to steal money or borrow money
from the fire prevention budgets to pay
for fire suppression and firefighting
and of course that ends up in a vicious
cycle where I guess what next year there
are more fires and as you guys know this
year has been one of the worst fire
seasons in living memory well it seems
every year is the worst fire season a
living memory and so how do we address
this problem as you said part of the
problem is that you know we've we've
essentially prevented all fires and
these systems these ecological systems
were effectively evolved to to deal with
lots of small fires and that's the way
they prevented the large fires and since
we've gotten rid of all those small
fires we're getting all the big fires so
the question is how do you have money in
hand to actually do the thinning and the
best management practices to to keep the
fuels off the land and that's what we
were trying to solve for here another
follow-up question from Andrew is have
you quantified the impact of Forex
pool forest thinning in terms of dollar
values of firefighting saved or cubic
feet of water increased we you know this
was this was a a relatively quick and
dirty study so we didn't get into all
those levels of detail what I should say
is that in our research we did come
across a lot of the good research that
others are doing including Nature
Conservancy and others and in some cases
so for instance the Nature Conservancy
has shown that in some watersheds
thinning has led to twenty percent more
water flows in the basin as a post to
not thinning so you know depends on the
on the on the basin and on the system to
get an exact number is kind of difficult
but what we can say is that it looks
like in most of these systems thinning
will lead to increased water flows in
the river systems how much in terms of
acre feet we haven't quantified although
that's something that that people could
do in terms of the the benefits and on
fire you know I think the Forest Service
has some ideas of of what would happen
and again tnc has done a number of
studies in particular in California
where they showed that that you know the
dollar spent in in fire prevention can
actually lead to huge savings in
firefighting so you know there there are
some studies out there and it wasn't the
role we were playing the role we were
playing was looking at some of those
studies and trying to say is there a way
for private capital to come in and what
that means is is there a way to provide
a return for investors for doing the
sorts of things that need to be done in
the patient to to help solve the water
problems great we have two questions
with regard to the agricultural
strategies the first is from Scott who's
asking if you can provide more details
on the opportunities presented by the
agriculture water use blueprints and
Megan who builds on that question with
what are the primary sources of returns
and waters
primary cashflow drivers Tom you want to
take that one sure um the first one was
specifics on with it on the regions or
the agricultural strategies so yeah I
think that I think in in looking at the
agricultural strategies and specifically
crop conversion the premise is that
you're looking for ways to continue a
agricultural output in these areas so
you're not you're not buying and drying
land so you want to find ways to finance
the conversion and finance the use of a
glance to stay in agriculture without
reducing the current yield from from
that acreage and so the the work that
were that we're looking at doing is you
know crop switching maybe from say a
very low value high water use crop into
a low water use high value specialty
crop in a way that the farmer is not
disadvantaged by switching to this other
crop but then also upgrading the
irrigation infrastructure in certain
areas so that you have more efficient
on-farm irrigation networks that allow
you to really i would say conserve that
water that you've saved so you can save
water but to the extent it's not
necessarily done on farm it's not just
transferable and then in certain areas
it doesn't even belong to you so you
have to kind of work within the system
of putting all those those various
things together to make it work does
that answer the question yeah the one
other point another blueprint which i
think is sort of interesting is that on
the the commodity index dryer option
which is great this sort of a different
approach when the the crop conversion
and and efficiency strategy is sort of
looking at a way in which you could
effectively pull help improve the use of
water in agriculture while keeping farms
in production ineptly than improving
sort of farm returns while saving some
water sort of that's a byproduct of
those activities you could monetize that
water as well but trying to get away
from a strategy where you're really just
doing it sort of buying up agriculture
and shutting it down in order to get at
that water value the commodity indexed
version is a sort of an effort I think
to address the sort of risk sharing
element while conversion and
conservation is maybe a way to address
supply-demand imbalance and shift water
from one use to another there's also a
really important need for sort of water
sharing between sectors in the context
of increasing variation there's a
metastructure out there for a long time
known as a drier option we're
effectively a user with a very low
tolerance for water risk like a city you
can't really add necessarily adapt their
water use in in the event of the drought
year because you know people there's
only so much you can do with
conservation and of course you know
people have trouble submix significantly
changing their water use you partner
with an entity with a high tolerance for
water use like a row crop farmer or an
apartment or some weed like that who
could potentially turn off their water
use without causing significant economic
damage and the city essentially pays
that entity to stop using water during
dry condition the challenge with that
arrangement and is not well it's been
out there a long time it's not been
widely used is that there are not been
very good ways to distribute those
economic and hydrologic risks and so
typically what has happened is that
farmers are faced with a really
uncertain situation where if they're
going to agree in advance they're going
to stop using water they don't know what
they're giving up or being asked to give
up in the year that they're going to
have to stop using it they don't know
what crop prices are going to be they
don't know what the for commodity
markets are going to look like that year
and so it's been very difficult ones
been practice that structure is actually
trying to do a better job of
distributing hydrologic and economic
risk between cities and farmers
essentially setting up a situation where
a city can make a very stable payment
sort of similar to an insurance premium
to an investor who will sort of
guarantee the access to a supply during
an extremely dry year where while the
investor also guarantees a payment to
the farmer that's equivalent to whatever
they could have earned farming based on
market prices that you're potentially
plus a premium and then the investor
does the job of sort of spreading that
risk out onto the commodities markets
through hedging transactions so it sets
up a situation where both sides gives
what they want the farmer is sort of
guaranteed a good income the city gets a
guaranteed supply at a known price that
they can build it to a regal and I
should add that one of the reasons why
we tried to focus on something that
isn't just buy and dry is that obviously
you know just removing agriculture has
huge political social and other
implications in this region and is much
more difficult politically whereas if
you can maintain some agricultural
production while still getting the water
benefits that's the ideal and also I
think we should say that in terms of
environmental impact it's key to know
where you're doing these these
activities because as we said every drop
of water is used multiple times so even
if you save it on a farm upstream it's
just getting you know it goes downstream
and is used by somebody else but what's
important environmentally or what can be
important environmentally is that flow
allowing for that flow to essentially
feed and provide water to ecosystems can
have huge environmental benefits so all
of these things were the sorts of things
we were trying to take into account
introducing these strategies great um a
question from me
what is the general rate of return
anticipated for these instruments and
what range of returns do impact
investors expect in order to invest in
this sector that's a you know I guess
John F Kennedy would have answered that
question by saying that's a very good
question next question please no i mean
i think that the it's a bit of a how
long is a piece of string question
because it depends on where you do these
things and how you do these things all
of that will impact the rates of return
you know we've produced some very kind
of call them notional models for each of
these strategies you know showing range
returns from the the low single digits
to the double digits or so but you know
that is just in theory now getting into
the practice is where it becomes much
much harder you know I think it was Yogi
Berra said in theory there's no
difference between theory and practice
but in practice there is well here's an
example of that of that actually
applying in terms of what the impact
investors will expect you know it also
varies varies widely I mean we've seen
impact investors who who are happy with
with low single digit returns if they
believe they're getting a significant
impact and we've seen others say no I
want you know double digits or or hire a
it because we believe it's possible and
you know all the types of impact
investments are very very different and
all the types of impact investors are
very very different you know we've even
seen some of them say look we're happy
with with just getting our principal
back if we have a huge impact but but
that is not the norm that is the that is
a the exception rather than the rule I'd
say the rule is you know they want
somewhere around market-based returns
and and they still want the impact so
they want it all they want their cake in
the a tattoo but I think there's also a
huge misunderstanding in the sector
there's this
leaf that that you know in order to get
returns you will give up impact and I
think there are investments where that
is the case but there are also
investments where that is not
necessarily the case we're actually
getting the impact in getting the
returned are the same thing and there
are cases where you know the greater
impact you have the less return you
expect or vice versa um so it's hard to
generalize across the space I'll let you
peruse the models once you see the
report and then we can talk about
whether you think where we've done a
good job or not but they all very highly
and as you saw in that bubble chart
before you know we've kind of gotten
some notions of what what we think the
returns will be and and try to plot them
out in this kind of way here where some
of the higher return ones are are being
driven by you know kind of agricultural
yield increases as well as land value
increases and then some of the others
are producing less return but
potentially hiring back so a question is
noting too that there's a number of
different structures and the strategies
that we proposed and that obviously can
change your your risk return profile so
finding ways to bring current yield or
repayment to the investor sooner
obviously increases your your financial
return but the idea is really showing
all term structures to potential
investors and seeing which ones work for
them and then which ones work for the
stakeholder so there's a lot of
different ways to structure them as well
yeah we haven't even begun the
negotiations with the you know take the
fire bond one that we talked about
that's going to be a negotiation between
say the Forest Service and the investor
and what's the Forest Service willing to
pay what's the investor willing to take
and you know we haven't begun that
negotiation so we've put some numbers in
there as placeholders but we'll see what
one one thing maybe just add there and
then move on to another question but i
think is to note that one of the places
where it
there is actually in particularly in
water an opportunity for impact
investment that is a bit unique compared
to private investment is the fact that
the fact that you are having those
positive impacts may in fact make some
ways an investment easier to do then if
it was a purely commercial transaction
there's been there's certainly a lot of
interest developing in sort of private
it sort of more direct private
investment in water and we've seen over
the last decade the entry of a lot of
private capital into water from looking
at the sort of fact of water scarcity
and this increasing risk and also this
huge price disparities that tend to
exist between what farmers pay for water
and what cities are willing to pay and
folks are getting into that thinking
they can essentially engage in arbitrage
and buy buy low and sell high in reality
the legal system makes a sort of
straight off water transactions fairly
difficult to accomplish which is many
ways why there are such significant
price disparities out there because it's
very difficult to move water from one
place to another but one of the easiest
ways to do that is in fact to
demonstrate that there are in fact
benefits environmental public and
otherwise associated with those
transactions so in that sense that's a
place where in some ways having your
cake and eating it too is actually
potentially possible for the impact
investor because the designing a
investment that is going to
affirmatively generate a set of public
benefits create benefits for the farm
community say in the in the conversion
scenario at by producing better yields
conserving water maybe even helping with
the transition of farmland from an aging
farm population to a younger generation
of farmers that want to enter the market
as well as generating some environmental
benefits in terms of stream flow that's
a that actually can become a pretty
pretty convincing case for why
a transfer should be allowed to take
place as opposed to I bought some water
cheap and I want to now dry out my dry
out of my firm land wreck the local
community and send it to say Los Angeles
another broader question from Andrew and
Lee is that in the near term they're
asking in the near term which model is
the most established and has the best
proven track record and what do you
foresee are the key barriers towards
implementing these projects and
replicating them to scale well I mean I
think some of them have not even been
you know implemented and therefore have
no track record and so we're facing the
situation of essentially bushwhacking
and trying to get these things done
where they have never been done before I
would say that to answer your question
pretty much the AG strategies are I
would say the closest to something that
has already been done and that is being
done out there so you know there are AG
investors and AG real estate investors
that that do go out there and they do
you know by land change land and base
their returns on either increased yield
or you know increases in the value of
the land itself and so that exists
that's out there what we're talking
about doing here is actually adding a
kind of water benefits kicker to that
kind of strategy so I would say that is
one of the ones that I think is is most
most like what's out there it doesn't
mean it's the it's the most doable it
doesn't mean it's the best it just is
more like what's already out there I
would say the the system lost strategy
which relies on fixing leaky pipes you
know the it's relatively straightforward
it just adds a the creation of the type
of LLC and a pay-for-performance
structure to it again you know pretty
straightforward pretty doable each of
them have their own separate barriers so
for instance in the fire bond the one of
the barriers is contracting in the
agricultural water use on the bed
is maybe how do you actually monetize
the water savings and they each have
very very different barriers so it's
kind of hard to answer that question
with 1 1 answer um but we believe all of
them are doable some may actually be
harder than others and in fact that
after we present this publicly and
encouraged and working with Peter we're
going to be looking at how do we
actually pick one or two of these and
try and implement them through encourage
yeah maybe I'm not ladder pointed and I
think they're all doable not all of them
as I think heard a mentioned earlier
necessarily doable everywhere we tried
to identify strategies that were
potentially be undertaken within sort of
existing regulatory constraints or with
very modest sort of changes somewhere in
the basin not necessarily not
necessarily everywhere so but you know
for example the fire button the
challenge is contracting at the federal
level but it may be possible to
implement on a on a private or state
level much more quickly so in many some
cases there's a sort of immediate
opportunity but it may be geographically
constrained or jurisdictionally
constrained but could perhaps help drive
the policy changes we can demonstrate it
in some environments drive some policy
changes would make it easier to
implement on a broader scale the one
other tool that I think we do have some
great examples I've already is actually
on the market development side in the
water storage trading and that's
actually a well not widely used in the
United States there are some excellent
examples of the use of markets to assist
with with water management in places
like Chile australia also in northern
Mexico
another broader question on that then
applies to the wider conservation impact
investing space is that many of the
investment models presented in the
report rely on returns generated by
enhanced or restored environmental
services provided by different aspects
of the watershed to what degree are
these financial models resilient to
considerable environmental risks how do
you account for significant variability
in these natural systems and to what
degree can you mitigate this risk well I
mean I think I actually am Not sure I
agree with the premise of the question I
don't think a lot of them do rely on the
on the increased ecosystem service
benefits provided by these the impact of
them may rely on that but the returns so
for instance again going back to the
agricultural user the return on that
strategy is as much from the yield
increases and the value of land as it is
from you know monetizing the water so
that doesn't rely at all on to some
degree on the on the ecosystem benefits
you know I'd say in fact most of them
don't rely on the ecosystem benefits in
part because we were trying to trying to
design invest those tools that that were
invested in today's environment so that
didn't expect a huge policy shifts or
policy changes or or even markets for
ecosystem services that would allow you
to monetize those those values that was
kind of our raiment so I would argue
most of these don't rely on that and
don't rely on on that environmental
benefit other than for the impact yes on
the impact you know we are relying we
are saying that that if you reduce fires
you're going to get some environmental
benefit and some water benefit and you
know there's a lot of good anecdotal and
research evidence to suggest that that
is correct
but as you point out it might not be as
much as we expected and and one of the
interesting things if you start doing
this on a broader level you get some
people interest interested in measuring
and monitoring those impacts so
hopefully it will lead to greater
research on on what is possible and what
can be done great one last question from
Scott who would like more detail and how
private investors should be interacting
with owners and operators of
agricultural lands to make those water
improvements and our investors mainly
interacting indirectly through market
transactions or do you foresee greater
involvement on the ground and the
classic economic question why aren't
these models already being done I think
I mean there's a variety of ways in
which investors are interacting with
folks on the ground I think one of the
sort of things that we came to
conclusion in this report is that what
making a lot of these structures work
really does rely on taking advantage of
the established relationships on the
ground that say NGOs and others have
been building for decades around around
environmental issues and and you know
farm community issues and other things
one of the there's a great deal of
suspicion generally in the agricultural
community about outside investment it's
not universally true certainly as you
get down into the sort of lower basin
states where we have very large scale
production agriculture with very
sophisticated producers many of whom are
our large corporations that's probably
less of the case there's a lot more
comfort with the idea that investors in
a sort of distant City may be the source
of capital I think as you move into
smaller communities there is
understandable and many with in many
cases very well justified suspicions
about
outside capital you know it's sort of
like the only thing scarier than where
the government and we're here to help
you is we're Wall Street and we're here
to help you so in in many cases I think
our conclusion has been that the way
that these things will need to be
developed will be with support from NGOs
from foundations from farm community
organizations that can sort of help to
sort of identify and also identify
potential opportunities and use
established relationships to sort of
build trust around these models and I
think that it also is in some part of
why we've not seen a great deal of this
in the past you know the sort of
traditional I think commercial
investment has really looked at these
problems as being sort of arm's length
market transactions in fact is has been
a sort of afraid of environments in
which what looked like arms like
transactions are difficult to accomplish
as a result of that a lot of the
conversation around water and how we're
going to facilitate more investment in
water has actually focused on how we can
improve markets and make water easier to
trade and treat it more like a
traditional commodity essentially take a
lot of the politics and relationships
and cultural values out of the equation
I think from our standpoint that's
actually not the right approach and
certainly not necessary we can develop
investments and identify these
opportunities within these existing
structures in many cases and it may in
many cases design investments that are
actually affirmatively beneficial to the
sort of cultural values the people are
trying to protect in places like the
Colorado River Basin and in fact I think
even in the sort of more commercial
sector what you're beginning to see is
that the most successful private
investments are the ones that are done
with a great deal of sensitivity and
focus
on the ground and so you know the
investors that you know they come in and
they may use outside capital to buy
farms but they make investments in those
communities they get elected to
irrigation district boards they work to
find ways to benefit the community as
well as themselves so that's an evolving
trend I think one that will be continued
that certainly probably need to be
increased in an impact of lasting model
there's also no Avenue really for direct
deal flow I mean come from a traditional
investing background you have a whole
infrastructure that allows for deal
development and deal flow you can tap
into and I think that doesn't
necessarily exist yet for some of the
strategies that we're proposing here and
I would just add to what Peter said
surprise surprise it's it's about
politics as much as it is about you know
finance and other things so you know
it's a all very very political and when
you get the two water it's a sometimes
even more political well you know well
what was the was it Mark Twain Peter
that said uh whiskeys for drinking and
waters for fighting well there you go
that might be a greatcoat to conclude
our talk on water in the West how impact
investing can help what do you think
Ricardo sounds good to me but you know
we're we're available we're happy to
make the full report in the executive
summary available so just the ping us I
think you have our emails if not my
email is our bio net encourage capital
all one word calm feel free to ping me
if any of any future questions and I'm
happy to forward that to Peter as well
so you have any questions for him or for
Tom as well well we would like to thunk
or three speakers for joining us this
afternoon if you would like to view a
recording of this webinar please visit
the Yale Center for Business on the
environment website or subscribe to the
nature's returns itunes podcast series
tuna
next Thursday October first for the
second webinar in this series feature
featuring Jill Whitworth of the
freshwater trust who will be discussing
his new book quantified and its
implications on conservation impact
investing this is Karina from the Yale
Center for Business on the environment
saying so long from New Haven
Connecticut